and I think that's what these process
are trying to do they're not trying to
say oh you're a woman let me hire you to
fill a quarter I guess saying look we're
saying we don't have women in our
company we want more women to be in our
company but we're not going to pick you
just because you're a woman but we want
you to feel like you are capable of
being here despite being a woman so I
think that is what these courses are
doing they're trying to encourage
participation as opposed to make people
feel like they're being picked based on
a specific demographic and I think
that's what they're trying to do but at
the end of the day I think it's still
sexist and I think it's offensive like I
think it's a fact yeah I think I think
it's offensive like why do I need a
quota to get a job like because I'm just
the type like I feel like I can do
anything and I like this YouTube section
is very male dominant like every job at
Birch has always been male dominated I
don't need a quota to help me get a job
and like to me like that's offensive
that you would think I would need a
quota when I'm the quiz like why don't
like to me it's like why do I care if
there's a man or a woman doing it I'm
gonna do it anyway